antigua colonia británica quien ya es un
buen pupilo de democracia y rendimiento
económico los casi 55 millones de
kenianos viven en un país
descentralizado su jefe de estado se
elige cada cinco años la población es
predominantemente cristiana y los
idiomas oficiales son el inglés y en su
ágil
en los últimos 20 años el desarrollo
económico ha sido considerable entre
2000 y 2021 el pib pasó de 397 dólares
per cápita a un poco más de dos mil
dólares para lograr este desarrollo el
país depende principalmente de su
producción agrícola y está recurriendo
al extranjero beijing para construir
grandes infraestructuras
el fmi y el banco mundial para financiar
su enorme deuda en la actualidad la
deuda pública supera los 67 mil millones
de dólares según el banco central de
kenia otro reto la pobreza ya que el 45
por ciento de los kenianos sigue
viviendo con menos de 2 dólares al día
el desafío más grande para los electores
en kenia es el costo de vida
el costo de vida se ha disparado lo que
ha vuelto muy dura la vida de la mayoría
de kenianos foliar ritz con estas
dificultades se ven agravadas por los
altos niveles de corrupción según la onu
en algunas regiones la pobreza se suma a
la inseguridad en especial al terrorismo
en el norte
una de las formas del estado para
abordar estos retos es la educación el
país dedico más del 5% de su pib a la
educación en 2018
en la actualidad el 99% de los niños
kenianos asisten a la escuela primaria